après quand on y repense c'était trop
bien à première vue perrine allouche est
une étudiante comme les autres mais
cette ville proviennent de 17 ans a créé
la sensation dans le monde du maquillage
en devenant meilleur apprenti de france
en octobre dernier avec son dessin sur
le thème du dragon chinois
elle a véritablement enflammé le jury
une grande émotion pour la jeune fille
repenser tout ce qu'on a travaillé les
pantoufles et moi ou on a s'est entraîné
avec mon professeur modèle même une
autre fille de ma classe qui a aussi
parcouru est comme moi le concours du
coup d'en repenser à tout ça et on dit
que maintenant on arrivé là et du coup
ça fait bizarre
vous aimez le court ici pourtant cette
yvelinoise n'est pas né avec cette
passion dans la peau le maquillage et
commencé quand je suis rentré en seconde
au lycée avant jeu mais attendez c'est
pas tellement c'était plutôt les ongs
que je faisais et c'est après avec les
cours ça m'a donné encore plus envie de
le faire et le concours du coup ça ça
m'a vraiment donné encore plus envie de
m'y intéresse quelqu'un six ans avant
d'arriver au strass et aux paillettes
d'un titre de meilleur apprenti perrine
allouche a répété ses gammes dans cette
salle de classe du lycée des métiers
florian aso c'est ainsi que j'ai été
formé c'est ici qu'on faisait les
entraînements donc à ma professeur
madame st martin donc c'est ici que tout
a commencé en fait dans la structure la
ville proviennent a pu bénéficier des
conseils de son enseignante miley
saint-martin meilleur ouvrier de france
en 2015 dans la section esthétique art
du maquillage pour elle le succès de sa
protégée ne fait aucun doute
elle est minutieuse dans ce qu'elle fait
et en esthétique il et il faut cette
qualité là et elle est toujours
agréable en cours et voilà elle
travaille très bien
des qualités qui pourraient comme dans
ses rêves les plus fous l'a propulsé
comme maquilleuse sur des défilés
français et internationaux dans les
années à venir
j'ai beaucoup d'objectifs en fait je
veux pas faire qu'une chose dans ma vie
je sais que j'ai envie de travailler
dans le maquillage de scène maquillage
artistique
pourquoi pas être professeur aussi mais
avant de penser à l'avenir perrine devra
obtenir son bac pro en juin prochain
un examen moins glamour qu'un titre
d'apprentis mais qui lui ouvrira les
portes du monde du travail